JENNA TAYLOR: Welcome.
Thank you everybody for
being here with us today.
And to our friends on
livestream and later on YouTube,
also thank you for joining us.
I'm Jenna Taylor.
I'm one of your food program
managers here in the Bay Area,
and I am super
excited to welcome you
to our panel in honor of
Women's History Month.
We are graced with
the presence of three
amazing female culinarians--
Tracy Des Jardins, Joanne
Weir, and Tanya Holland.
Welcome to Google.
TANYA HOLLAND: Thank you.
JOANNE WEIR: Thank you.
TRACI DES JARDINS: Thank you.
JENNA TAYLOR: So I assume
everybody here knows you well,
as I do.
But introduce yourself.
Give me your-- how do
you identify yourself?
Knowing you're all
women of many talents.
When you meet someone,
you say, I'm Tanya.
I'm--
TANYA HOLLAND: Chef and owner of
Brown Sugar Kitchen restaurant
in Oakland.
I always like to make sure
people know it's in Oakland.
JENNA TAYLOR: What
about you, Joanne?
JOANNE WEIR: So, I do a
lot of different things.
I've written-- I'm
a cookbook writer,
I've written 17 cookbooks.
I own a restaurant in Sausalito,
Copita, modern Mexican.
I have a television show.
I've been on television
for 17 years--
PBS and Create.
And there's one more
thing-- oh, and I also--
I actually teach all over.
I'm really a teacher first.
I probably should have
said teaching first.
But I rent villas in Italy,
France, Spain, Morocco,
and Greece, and I
spend weeks each year,
four weeks each year,
Spring and Fall,
to take people to
spend a week with me
in these beautiful villas.
So I do a lot of
different things.
I love my job.
JENNA TAYLOR: Sounds
like a job worth loving.
Yeah, absolutely.
Tracy, what about you?
TRACI DES JARDINS: I
always introduce myself
as Tracy Des Jardins,
chef and restaurateur.
I'm based in San Francisco.
I like to call myself a cook.
And that's how I started out.
That's what I still am--
I'm sort of most
grounded in that world
of the tactile
relationship with food.
So that's kind of--
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah, absolutely.
In fact, I'm very
interested in that.
How did you start out?
How did you-- what made you
want to become a cook or a chef?
TRACI DES JARDINS: I went
to college when I was 16.
I graduated from
high school early
and went to UC
Santa Cruz and kind
of bottomed out pretty quickly.
And I had a passion
for two things--
skiing and cooking.
And I'd taken cooking on as a
hobby when I was in high school
and skied my whole life.
And my parents were
really pissed at me,
so they weren't going to support
my desire to be a ski bum.
And so I said, OK, well,
I'm going to become a cook.
And I quickly landed in a really
serious kitchen in Los Angeles.
And I didn't ski
for like 15 years.
So it didn't exactly turn out
the way that I had intended,
but I can't complain.
JENNA TAYLOR: So
first let me say,
I also went to UC
Santa Cruz, so you're
in the presence of
multiple Banana Slugs.
TRACI DES JARDINS:
All right, cool.
JENNA TAYLOR: But beyond--
you also went to Europe
and trained, didn't you?
TRACI DES JARDINS: Yeah, I did.
JENNA TAYLOR: Tell us just a
little bit about what that's
like, not only as an
American-- which I know
makes it difficult--
but as a woman.
Do you feel like it was
a different experience?
TRACI DES JARDINS:
Yeah, so this was--
I went to France to work
for the first time in 1986.
And I worked in four
different kitchens in France.
Two of them were three star
kitchens, and two of them--
Michelin-- three star kitchens,
and two were two stars.
I was the only woman in
all of those kitchens.
And I was the only
American in three
out of four of those kitchens.
And so it was--
I was kind of way ahead of
the curve in terms of people
who started looking at going
to Europe and studying food.
At that point in time,
there were really
not restaurants in
the United States
that were of that same caliber.
We didn't have restaurants
then like the French Laundry,
and Alinea, and all of
these Michelin two and three
star restaurants.
And so if you really wanted
that kind of exposure,
you had to go to France.
And France was kind
of the stronghold
at that point in time for
that tier of restaurants.
So it was very difficult,
to answer your question.
It was-- I didn't speak
French when I went.
Although I had food
technology-- those terms
were part of the vernacular
that we used in kitchens here.
But it was a new frontier.
But I lived and breathed
what I was doing and had
a strong desire to take what
I could from that experience.
And so I could ignore
a lot of the stuff that
was really challenging.
JENNA TAYLOR: I
think we all learn
how to filter that stuff out
when we're doing what we love,
right?
TRACI DES JARDINS: Exactly.
JENNA TAYLOR: Joanne,
what about you?
How did you decide you wanted
to be a chef or a cook?
JOANNE WEIR: I don't think
I really had a choice.
My mother was a professional
cook, my grandfather,
my great grandmother.
So for me it was just--
I learned food from the
time I was an infant.
Food was very important
in my family's home.
I remember going and spending
every single Saturday
during the summer
at my grandfather's
farm in the Berkshires.
And he had butchered
the chicken.
He had made the rolls.
He had everything-- made
homemade mayonnaise.
He made potato chips.
We would sit under
the maple trees,
and they were these
beautiful maple trees
that he had even made
his own maple syrup.
And we would have maple
walnut ice cream for dessert
that he hand churned.
So for me--
I thought every kid
grew up like that.
I really did.
I just had this very
charmed, delicious kind
of upbringing from both
sides of my family.
So I think for me, really,
food was just something
that was just in my blood.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's just life.
JOANNE WEIR: But I
did go to school.
I studied fine arts
and also art education.
And I taught in
Boston for a few years
before I said, oh
my god, I can't do
this for the rest of my life.
And then I went to study--
and then I started cooking
with Madeleine Kamman.
So very strong female
role models in my life.
My mother and Madeleine
Kamman and Alice Waters.
So that's kind of my
background with food.
JENNA TAYLOR: Love it.
What about you, Tanya?
TANYA HOLLAND: I've been
fascinated with kitchens
since I was little.
So my-- one thing I remember
growing up-- when I was five,
we moved into our first home.
And in the garage I had
a miniature refrigerator
stored in the sink.
And I was always in
there making something.
I don't know.
And then I got my
Easy Bake Oven,
and my dad showed me how to
make my first cake from scratch.
And my parents are
from the South,
and they had this
gourmet cooking
club when I was growing up.
So all our entertainment
and social life
was around cooking
and entertaining.
So when I got to
college, like Joanne,
I thought everybody
lived like this.
None of my kids--
um, none of my kids--
none of my fellow
classmates knew how to cook.
They were all ramen noodles
and peanut butter and jelly.
And so I started hosting dinner
parties and started studying.
Ended up with a degree--
JENNA TAYLOR: It worked out OK.
TANYA HOLLAND: Ended
up with a degree
in Russian language
and literature.
Didn't really do a lot with
that until two years ago,
which I'll explain later.
And then after school
I started working
in restaurants in college.
But I worked in the front
of the house for seven years
before I went to cooking
school in France.
And then I knew I wanted
to be a restaurateur,
but I really wanted
to know the food.
A lot of the most
successful restaurants
are chef owner operated.
So--
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
how do you feel
that front-of-house time
informs your experience
as a restaurateur?
TANYA HOLLAND: Oh, it's great.
It's significant.
And I think both sides
should experience
working on both sides.
You have understanding for their
needs of timing and information
and education as a chef.
What's necessary?
Also you know what's possible
and what's not possible.
But I think, yeah,
it's really important.
JENNA TAYLOR: One of the
things we were talking about--
spoiler alert,
before we started--
is this really
fascinating correlation
between what I see as women
in tech and women in food.
They're both traditionally
male-dominated industries.
And I think there's
still a lot of work
to be done in order to get
some measure of equity--
if we ever get there.
What is-- I'm very
interested in your thoughts
on-- how can we move the needle?
Google's trying to do a
lot of work at our scale.
But what does that look
like in the food industry?
How can we affect change
in bringing more women
to the fore?
Anyone.
JOANNE WEIR: It seems so strange
to me that we even say this.
Because I always think
of women as the cooks.
I mean, we're the nurturers.
So for me, when I worked at Chez
Panisse, I was the only woman.
Like Traci said, I
was the only woman
in the kitchen for about
three years in the cafe.
And honestly, I didn't think
really anything about that.
I really didn't see it as odd.
It's only now that I
feel like I'm really
looking at that much more.
I don't know.
TRACI DES JARDINS: I
used to think that we
should ignore the gender--
I mean, the way that I got
through the obstacles that
stood in my way was to
never really think about it.
And to kind of think of
myself as just one of the guys
and get through it.
And for a long time I sort of
said, you can't focus on that.
And didn't really believe that
as a female chef, restaurateur,
running kitchen, that I should
actually help or facilitate
women's betterment
in the kitchen,
or really promote them, or
give them an extra hand.
I just thought, oh,
I'm going to treat
everyone exactly the same.
And I think that that
obligation actually
needs to shift a little bit.
And we who have made it
need to extend ourselves
beyond just sort of that
standard of treating everyone
the same and
facilitate a leg up.
And that doesn't
mean that you have
to make choices differently or
necessarily that you would hire
somebody that was
less talented, per se,
but just to seek resources
and support and access.
And that's something I've
set about personally to do
is to kind of try and reach
my hand out a little bit
and give a leg up where I can.
JOANNE WEIR: I
think that's great.
One of the things I
said to you before--
I did this--
I was a judge for
the Good Food Awards.
And I was telling you this.
I was talking to
John Scharffenberger,
and we were just
sitting there and having
this great conversation.
And this young woman walked
up and she said, Joanne,
I want to talk to you
just for a second.
She said, I'm so sorry
to interrupt you,
but I want to thank you,
because you've been such a role
model for women in the kitchen.
And honestly, I was shocked.
I had never, ever
thought about that.
And I'm telling you-- that was
like two or three years ago.
I had never-- and I'm just
curious, have you ever
thought about that yourselves?
TANYA HOLLAND: I think about
it all the time, personally.
And I want to quote this.
There was a woman--
I was at an event
not too long ago--
and she said a line.
I was like, I'm
going to say that.
So I've been a black
woman my entire life.
I don't know any other thing.
So I don't know which experience
is really affecting some
of the challenges I've had.
Am I being-- is it
gender or is it race?
And it's both.
And I can't really separate it.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's
probably both.
TANYA HOLLAND: But I never--
point is, I didn't
see a lot of people
who looked like me
doing what I wanted
do coming up in
restaurants, and I never
found the mentor that I wanted.
My goal is to
mentor and to become
that role model for young women
of color, or people of color,
or just whoever wants to
get access to information.
Access to opportunity that
I blatantly did not receive
because of what I look like.
Whichever reason that could be.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's great.
TANYA HOLLAND: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: I think
it's interesting.
Because you go back between--
I started my career
in construction
and now being in food--
clearly both very
male-dominated fields.
And I saw at a young age, the
choices were-- act like a man
or be ostracized as other.
And I don't like either
of those choices.
MULTIPLE SPEAKERS: No.
TANYA HOLLAND: Yeah.
TRACI DES JARDINS: I think that
that's a really important point
that I think that we
have tried to define
successful women
in the same terms
that we define successful men.
And we're such
different creatures
that we need to actually come
up with really different ways
to value women's qualities.
And they're not going
to be qualities that
are the same as successful men.
JENNA TAYLOR: Nor
should they be.
TRACI DES JARDINS:
Nor should they be.
And that's where we
have to really break out
of this thinking.
And I think that's where we get
into this, "powerful women are
bitches" or any of
this kind of stuff.
TANYA HOLLAND: That's what
I was going to say also.
When we have similar
attributes as men,
if we're ambitious, if we're
stern, if we're direct,
then it's also translated in
such a different language.
JENNA TAYLOR:
We're intimidating.
TRACI DES JARDINS: Absolutely.
JENNA TAYLOR: And
she's so bitchy.
TRACI DES JARDINS: Bitchy.
Right, right.
Bitchy.
JOANNE WEIR: I was in
a meeting with women--
with several powerful
women the other day.
And a man kind of lost it in
a very unprofessional way.
And all the women in the
room looked at each other
like, I'd never
get away with this.
But I'm so interested
in a new paradigm.
There has to be a way,
to your exact point,
to represent an
other that can be
prominent and unique and
special and doesn't have to be
replicative of what's existing.
TRACI DES JARDINS: And that's
the model that we need,
and that we need to look
for, and we need to support.
Because you even see--
I think you even see women
categorizing women like that.
JENNA TAYLOR: Very much so.
TRACI DES JARDINS: And
that's super problematic.
We don't support each
other, I think, often.
And we criticize
certain attributes,
and that's just not going to
get us where we need to go.
TANYA HOLLAND: Well, and also
the expectation that's set.
This is definitely
something that
comes up in race discussions.
When people have
low expectations--
I've had that happen
to me, myself.
And they're like,
you speak languages?
You went to college?
It's like, yeah, uh-huh, I did.
But also--
JENNA TAYLOR: Which languages?
Russian.
TANYA HOLLAND: They
don't expect us
to have these-- to be driven.
Or they have expectations
of, like, oh, she's
got to be matronly
and nurturing.
And I have people who-- that's
their projection towards me.
I'm like, no, I'm good.
I don't need to pretend
to be your mother.
So there's-- like you said,
something's got to change
around--
TRACI DES JARDINS:
There's one more point
I'd like to make
on this, because I
think it's really important.
I actually have not felt
that much discrimination
coming up through the ranks.
And I don't feel that my
gender actually held me back.
And sometimes I think it
was actually it was a plus.
But age-- I just
turned 50 last year.
And now I'm really
feeling that sense
of discrimination in our world
that I never felt before.
And it is crushing.
It makes me really
angry, because I
think we've got a huge
issue in this country
in particular around age.
And particularly--
absolutely against women.
Because it's fine--
JOANNE WEIR: You mean,
why you can't even
tell your age, actually.
TRACI DES JARDINS: Well, I do.
I make a point of doing it.
JOANNE WEIR: Well,
you might not after.
JENNA TAYLOR: But I
think it works-- age
can work in both directions.
Like, I experienced it as being
a young woman in an industry
where-- disrespected
by older men.
So it seems the
theme that I hear
is that really
erasing all of that
categorically, to have it
be more about authenticity
and representing, to your
point, like an authentic self
as a role model, not a "woman"
or a specific type of role
model.
But just that seeing more
successful authentic people
of all types be more prominent
and outspoken about that
could potentially have impact.
TRACI DES JARDINS: Absolutely.
TANYA HOLLAND: Well,
I think we don't all
want to be defined by
how we are outwardly.
I mean, I get that a lot,
where I get put into a box
and defined by how I look.
And I never define
myself that way.
But you realize when you
go into a room, or a space,
or whatever, and people--
they think they have
you figured out.
And we all do--
I guess we all profile
to a certain extent.
JENNA TAYLOR: It seems
that-- yeah, absolutely.
I think we do.
And I think a lot-- especially
being at Google-- about the way
that technology and media
and the accessibility
of information-- like
this is going to be
livestream and on YouTube.
So what is essentially a
pretty intimate conversation
here could potentially
reach thousands of people,
and I believe it will.
What do you guys
think about the ways
that we can leverage technology
to move this conversation
across a larger scale?
Is that useful?
And if not, what do we do?
Grassroots?
Community?
The Women's March on--
around the-- I was going
to say on Washington,
but I was in Oakland,
and it was big there.
JOANNE WEIR: I
was in Washington,
and it was very, very powerful.
JENNA TAYLOR: Clearly
there was a presence there.
TRACI DES JARDINS: It was
incredible and peaceful and
positive.
JOANNE WEIR: And supportive.
JENNA TAYLOR: Right.
Not a single arrest.
TRACI DES JARDINS: Inclusive.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Inclusive of everyone.
So the power's there.
How do we tap into it?
JOANNE WEIR: That's
what we're trying
to figure out through
conversations like this.
TANYA HOLLAND:
And like you said,
it's about access for anyone,
whether it's minority or women.
Someone asked me
earlier today, what
is one of your biggest
business challenges?
And I said, access to capital,
access to real estate,
access to information.
Access.
That's it.
I am motivated.
I am direct.
I know exactly what I want.
But if doors don't
open, if you're not
at the table where certain
parties who can influence
and effect change,
then what can you
do if you don't have access?
TRACI DES JARDINS: Yeah,
and that's a real thing.
I mean, I look at
some of my peers
who've been on a
parallel trajectory.
And a lot of them have
been a lot more successful
than I have, because they've
had business partners that
have swept in and
done that part of it.
I mean, I'm kind of a one-woman
show in terms of not having
that absolute business partner.
I've tried a few
times and actually not
had great success with
finding the right person.
And so I do all
that stuff myself.
So I'm doing the
business side of it,
and I'm doing the
creative side of it.
And it's a lot.
It's really cumbersome.
And it's-- and I look
at my peers out there,
and they've got it nailed.
And they've got
somebody that's managing
that whole side of fundraising
and real estate acquisition
and all of that stuff.
And there are probably
a lot of reasons
why that's the case, but--
JOANNE WEIR: I do have a really
strong partner, Larry Mindel
being a very strong partner.
And I've learned a ton from him.
But also, he's great
about working with women
and very respectful.
And so I've had a
really great experience.
I've been really lucky.
And I also came to
restaurants very late.
I mean, I've only been
in this for five years.
You've been how many?
TRACI DES JARDINS: 34.
TANYA HOLLAND: 30.
As Traci was saying, I can give
a lot of examples of her peers
who are male that
are not as talented,
but they get the access.
And they have major--
TRACI DES JARDINS: Empires.
TANYA HOLLAND: Empires, exactly,
that what I was looking for.
Because men tend to finance men.
And they tend to create a team.
A banker told me that
years ago in Boston.
Like, men won't-- it'll
be like a football team.
Let's just get together
and make this happen.
Let's win.
And we don't operate in
that same way-- women.
We're more collaborative.
And I don't know.
It's just different.
TRACI DES JARDINS: Maybe
we should have just
learned to play golf.
[LAUGHTER]
TANYA HOLLAND: I
still regret that.
My dad--
JENNA TAYLOR: It's a joke,
but I did take golf lessons
because so many of my meetings
happen on the golf course.
So one of the things that
the Google Food program has
been working on over
the past five years
is a small business incubator
program specifically
around food trucks.
So we have a food
truck fleet here
that we created in
partnership with Off the Grid.
But we have a small offshoot
of that called Instructional,
where we get people, especially
women and minorities, who
want to operate a food
truck and have an idea.
And then we work with them over
time to incubate their concept,
and design their
truck, and their menu,
and then we teach them
how to operate it.
And then we let them
operate it on campus
to get going for a
year, and then we
send them out into the world.
And I'm listening
to this conversation
and I'm thinking that there's
potential offshoot here
where we could begin growing
an incubator to connect people
with the access.
Because if Google's
whole mission
is to organize the
world's information
and make it universally
accessible--
and I think that there's
potential we should discuss.
TANYA HOLLAND: And I don't think
we've really addressed here,
how could the tech and how
does that come through?
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
What can we do?
TANYA HOLLAND: Go ahead, Traci.
TRACI DES JARDINS: No, no.
You go.
TANYA HOLLAND: No, I
was just going to say,
again, it's accessing
to diverse communities.
Where I am in West
Oakland, not everybody
has internet access
or computer access.
JENNA TAYLOR: We're
working on that.
Literally.
TANYA HOLLAND: I think that
would be really, really great.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Universal internet is
a huge project in multiple
ways at Google right now.
And I think we'll make make some
progress on that, but still--
TANYA HOLLAND: And also
realize in particular-- well,
you have a restaurant now--
in the restaurant
business, we have
such diverse social economic--
diversity as well.
So a lot of our employees
don't have the same access.
And that's where we are very
different from the tech world.
Most everyone who works with
you-- even though they might
be different ethnicities--
they have a college degree,
similar economic backgrounds.
But we are just
all over the place.
JENNA TAYLOR: I'll say that's
true maybe of Googlers,
but we even just
on the food team
have like 4,000 partners who
help us operate our program who
are everything
along the spectrum
of socioeconomic status.
TANYA HOLLAND: Oh, great.
JENNA TAYLOR: So we think
quite a lot about quality
of life for those people,
and the jobs that they're in,
and growth within those
jobs, and quality of life.
Many of them commute
in several hours
and work another job in the day.
TANYA HOLLAND: Well, then
this might be a sore subject,
but we've got to figure
out how we don't lose all
of our good cooks to you guys.
JENNA TAYLOR: I agree.
I need them.
But I know you need them, too.
TANYA HOLLAND: It's
really, really challenging
for us in the Bay Area.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
We were speaking about
this a little bit,
like the flipping
of the model for not
only wages within the food--
especially in the Bay Area-- but
within what the jobs even are.
So what do you think
are some of the things
that you see shifting
that are going to continue
to evolve in the coming years?
TRACI DES JARDINS: I
think that there's just
got to be greater efficiency.
I mean, in traditional
restaurants
you go through this whole
process of taking a carrot,
dirty from the field, and
processing it down the road.
I think that having some
consolidation of those efforts
that we all repeat in
our individual places
are solutions that could happen
around things like food prep.
I think we need big solutions.
The economic model is just not
working in restaurants anymore
at all.
And we all believe in a higher
hourly wage and minimum wage--
and believe in it absolutely--
and health care for everyone.
There's no question that those
things should be in place.
However, the burden to us as
business owners is too great
and is taking out our
entire profitability.
And we're in a crisis.
And that crisis
has really started,
I think, in San
Francisco, because we've
been enduring these business
burdens for, I don't know,
8 to 10 years now.
But that's starting to kind
of march across the country.
And as that happens, we're
going to see a lot more people
respond to it.
And you see it a lot in
the press these days.
The model's really broken.
And we need a new one.
And so we've got to
find those efficiencies.
It's not clear, though.
I don't think it's clear to
anybody what that path is.
JOANNE WEIR: I think
it's especially
hard in San Francisco.
It's really hard and
especially because of tech.
It's really difficult.
It's difficult to find
front of house, back
of house, everything.
TRACI DES JARDINS: It's
the cost of living, too.
And it's-- I think that the
city created a lot of subsidies
for these big companies to
come in and have San Francisco
as their headquarters, which
has driven up the real estate
prices and made it really
untenable for the minimum wage
folks to be able to survive.
And even at $16 an
hour, that minimum wage
is not going to
solve the problem.
Not even close.
It's the same conversation
we're seeing everywhere.
TANYA HOLLAND: Whereas we--
I don't know about
you, but I wasn't
paid when I cooked in France.
We made investments
in our career,
but it's not really feasible
anymore for people to do that--
to work for free, to work
for cheap, thinking like--
JENNA TAYLOR: I'll sleep
on a park bench for a time.
Not so much, anymore.
So what problems can a company
like Google help to solve?
What could we do to
help at a large scale?
TANYA HOLLAND: I don't know.
Subsidize our line cooks?
JOANNE WEIR: Yeah,
that's a good one.
TANYA HOLLAND: Maybe
there's some mutual benefit,
like they work for us
for a couple years,
and then they come
to Google cafeteria.
JOANNE WEIR: Housing
would be good.
TRACI DES JARDINS:
I think there has
to be an appreciation for
the tactile nature of food.
The hospitality industry--
we're nourishing people,
we're welcoming them
into an environment where
we're taking care of them.
And we need greater efficiencies
in terms of how that's done.
But you also don't want to
make it so technological
that you lose that tactile
relationship with it.
There's probably some virtual
way that you could eat food.
But would that--
JENNA TAYLOR: Doesn't
sound delicious.
TRACI DES JARDINS:
No it doesn't.
And it's so basic to our nature.
Food is such a basic thing.
You don't really want to
take it so far away from--
it's really special in that way.
And so it's
challenging, I think,
because you can think of a
million technological ways
in which you could change the
experience in a restaurant.
But do we really
want to do that?
JENNA TAYLOR: I don't
think-- maybe front of house
not as much.
It seems there's got to be some
efficiencies or innovations
in the kitchen space,
or in the supply chain,
or production chain,
or some of those jobs.
Like, we were speaking a
little bit about dishwashers,
dishwashing.
It's really difficult to
find dish machine operators
and similarly really
difficult to find
people to pick the food.
Those jobs-- we find the
median age rises year over year
every year, because there
aren't younger people coming
into those roles.
So those are the
places where we look
for the potential for technology
to really change the game.
TRACI DES JARDINS:
And I think it
is going to be in
robotics and the ability
to do some kind of basic
prep stuff that is--
there could be a
lot of innovation
around a machine that
could shuck fava beans
and take the membrane off of
them and that kind of stuff.
Because it takes hours and
hours and hours of people's time
to do that kind of thing.
And it's not efficient.
And to have a human being
doing that is not necessary.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah,
that's one of the biggest
things we try to do for
our chefs' teams here,
is we're always looking for
ways to cut out the lowest
value, least satisfaction
jobs, so that people can
do better, more creative work.
We always say, use the robots
for the work that nobody
wants to do, and then
let the people do
the really good stuff.
TRACI DES JARDINS: Like trash.
It's the last thought
that anyone ever
puts into designing something,
but it is so important.
I talk about garbage a lot.
I don't know why.
It's a big thing in kitchens.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's a huge thing.
And in fact, I'm very
interested in your thoughts.
So waste and waste management
and environmental impact
is really big here.
How do you think about
waste in your operations?
JOANNE WEIR: Carefully.
TRACI DES JARDINS: It's
really interesting.
Because I think it was
about 14 years ago that I
set about trying to
figure out how to-- it
was before San Francisco had
a really great composting
program.
And so we started to do it
ourselves and figure out
a program where we
could contain the waste
and send the compostable
stuff back to the farmers.
And now we're sort of at the
forefront of that whole idea.
Again, we can create much
greater efficiency with regards
to all that.
Because it is still
pretty archaic
in terms of how it's done.
JOANNE WEIR: But we're
much more efficient
than we were, much more--
even just a few years ago.
TRACI DES JARDINS:
And leaving a lot less
of an environmental footprint.
I mean, we now--
the percentage of our
garbage that goes to landfill
is now less than 10%.
Where 14 years ago, when
we started this work,
it was probably more like 90%.
Because it was
probably just bottles
that were being recycled.
So that's a great leap.
But you think about
the sorting and all
of that stuff that
still goes on,
and we could create
much greater efficiency.
Because it's still going from
me to the garbage facility,
getting composted,
when it really
should just be going
directly back to the farms.
Because we already
have those pathways.
And so why isn't that happening?
TANYA HOLLAND: We have
a community garden
down the street that
we compost with.
So it's literally
three blocks away.
So that's been really helpful.
So our compost-- because
we used to let it build up,
and then it gets really
stinky, and we get
flies, and all that stuff.
But now we don't have
to worry about that.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's
great, and you
can see it going right
back into your community.
TANYA HOLLAND: And
we're ahead the game
in the Bay Area as well, too.
Where if you go back east--
TRACI DES JARDINS:
In New York, I
don't think-- they still
don't have greenways there,
I don't think.
And it's like, they're
taking all this garbage
and putting it on these
barges and sending it
out to the landfill.
It's insanity.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's
truly frightening.
I can't even think about that.
So what do you see as
the future of food?
Where are we going
with food in America?
What's next?
TANYA HOLLAND: Well, I know
what I don't want to see.
I don't want to see so much
automation that we're not
having dining experiences.
There's so--
JENNA TAYLOR: No more--
Eatsa can't take over the world?
Nobody there to talk to
you to order your food.
TANYA HOLLAND: No.
I mean, a combination of it.
And I understand grab and
go, the importance of that.
But I think--
JOANNE WEIR: Fast casual.
TANYA HOLLAND: I'm
working on a fast casual--
JOANNE WEIR: Oh, I know.
Me, too.
TANYA HOLLAND: Everybody
is because we're trying
to make money in the industry.
JENNA TAYLOR: Absolutely.
TRACI DES JARDINS: I think
that's where the curve is going
is that fast food and what we've
done as fine dining for so long
are starting to merge together.
And we're seeing--
I mean, I think
also food TV has changed food.
When I started 34 years
ago, what we did in fine
dining was just
this very small--
was for a very small
section of the population.
And now, food is in everyone's
living room every night.
And that's--
JOANNE WEIR: Yes, thank you.
TRACI DES JARDINS: Exactly.
Thank you, Joanne.
JENNA TAYLOR: I did see
you on "Top Chef Masters".
TRACI DES JARDINS: Yes, indeed.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's true.
TRACI DES JARDINS:
And you can look at it
positively or negatively.
I feel like we've had this
whole world opened up now
where everyone in the
United States and beyond
knows about our restaurants
and our food and food culture.
And there's an aspiration,
even if they've never
been exposed to
it, that they think
in the back of
their mind, I want
to go and eat in this particular
kind of restaurant one day.
And that's super cool.
JOANNE WEIR: I want
to go to Norway
and eat in this
particular restaurant.
But I think what's
really great is
the simplicity and
the direction of that
and the focus on ingredients.
I think it's so great.
And I know we've been
going that way for so long.
But I think right
now I love that.
I just I think that that's--
I'm so happy that that's
how people are thinking.
And I know your food is
probably not in that direction,
and I'm so happy that it's
not molecular gastronomy.
But I think that one thing
that you do very well though
is to really--
you're able to find
things through Google.
So we really have to
thank you for that.
Because we can find anything,
and anything we want to eat,
or anything we want to buy,
or anything-- any place
we want to go to eat.
So thank you for that.
JENNA TAYLOR: The world's
information and making
it universally accessible.
Yes.
I will pass that along.
JOANNE WEIR: So you
continue to do that.
Thank you.
JENNA TAYLOR: We will.
We will.
What do you think?
TANYA HOLLAND: Yeah,
I was just thinking.
I was like, so
maybe a Google Cafe
or like a little Google
station in West Oakland
that that neighborhood could
have access to information,
access to--
JENNA TAYLOR:
We've been lobbying
for an Oakland outpost.
And there's a lot of
us who live in the East
Bay who wish that was the case.
TANYA HOLLAND: In West Oakland,
though, that could also
benefit the community somehow.
It's sort of like the
last frontier that's
right in the center of the Bay.
That's still a very
under-served community.
JENNA TAYLOR: I love that idea.
We'll circle back.
We'll talk afterwards.
I like it.
TANYA HOLLAND:
Selfishly, of course.
I want you there, too.
JENNA TAYLOR: Absolutely.
So when you're not cooking,
what do you love to do?
JOANNE WEIR: Travel
TANYA HOLLAND: Eat.
JENNA TAYLOR: Eat and travel.
Those go together, I think.
You travel to eat
at different places.
Or at least I do.
TANYA HOLLAND: Yeah.
Definitely travel
to eat for sure.
TRACI DES JARDINS: My job
isn't a lot of cooking anymore,
sadly, so I actually
cook at home a lot.
JOANNE WEIR: Isn't
that the best?
TRACI DES JARDINS:
Yeah, it is the best.
And it's a totally
different experience
than cooking in restaurants.
It's become sort of a hobby.
It's become a hobby now
instead of a profession.
JOANNE WEIR: I made this--
this year, January
1st, I was like,
I am not going to sit in
front of the computer all day
anymore.
I mean, I still do it.
But I said, I'm
going to cook more.
I'm really going to cook more.
And I've been doing
the same and loving it.
Because that's the thing
that I love the most.
Obviously that's why
we all got into it.
And we've stepped
so far away from it.
JENNA TAYLOR: OK.
So you had a really rough day,
what do you make for yourself?
JOANNE WEIR: Roasted chicken.
JENNA TAYLOR: Ah, that's mine.
JOANNE WEIR: Roasted
chicken would be mine.
TRACI DES JARDINS:
I make Mexican food.
I mean that's my comfort food.
JENNA TAYLOR: What's your go-to?
TRACI DES JARDINS: You know,
I love to make carnitas.
That takes a little while.
It's kind of a long cook time.
But any kind of tacos.
I love making salsas.
I make all different kinds.
And I love to make them at home.
The other day I made
a really simple one.
It was just boiled
tomatillos and chopped up
serrano chili and cilantro.
I mean, it was so
simple, because I just
didn't have anything else.
Usually I use a lot
of dried chilies.
And it was incredibly delicious.
I just ground it in a
molcajete, because I didn't even
want to turn the blender on.
I just wanted the quiet--
JOANNE WEIR: You wanted to cook.
You really wanted
to get in there.
TRACI DES JARDINS: I just wanted
the whole tactile experience.
And dead simple and so
delicious-- three ingredients.
JENNA TAYLOR: What
about you, Tanya?
TANYA HOLLAND: I go out.
JENNA TAYLOR: So
where do you go?
TANYA HOLLAND: I
love to be served.
I love the dining experience.
JENNA TAYLOR: So where's your
favorite place to go right now?
TANYA HOLLAND:
Actually, I really
love The Cook and Her Farmer.
I love raw meat.
JENNA TAYLOR: I was
just there last weekend.
TANYA HOLLAND: Her
flavors are so good.
Her food's so clean and local.
JENNA TAYLOR: Swan's
Market in Oakland--
amazing food stalls.
TANYA HOLLAND: I
usually sit there
at the counter and talk to
her while she's cooking.
JENNA TAYLOR: Cooking her
farmers-- one of them.
TANYA HOLLAND: Which is what
I hate when people do to me.
They talk to you.
But she's good, she talks--
we talk about-- we talk
about the business,
and how we can't find help,
and how expensive it is.
JENNA TAYLOR: Sorry about that.
TANYA HOLLAND: But anyways.
JOANNE WEIR: I have to
tell you my other one.
Because I've been spending
a lot of time in Morocco,
and I've been making
tagines left and right.
When you started to
talk about Mexican--
mine is Moroccan right now.
I love the flavors--
preserved lemons and cumin and--
love it.
JENNA TAYLOR: Amazing.
So favorite Bay
Area restaurant--
you got me thinking about it
with Cook and Her Farmer--
right now.
Not one of your own.
JOANNE WEIR: I love
Octavia right now.
TANYA HOLLAND: I
haven't been there yet.
JOANNE WEIR: I love it.
I like-- it's right around
the corner from my house.
It's so easy.
But I like it.
JENNA TAYLOR: What do you think?
TRACI DES JARDINS: I still
go back to Zuni all the time.
I probably have been
to that restaurant
more than any restaurant
my entire life.
And I just always love it.
It's just the vibe.
It's that room.
And the new chef,
just bless her,
is really upholding Judy's
whole vision for food.
And it hasn't changed,
which I think is remarkable,
that her vision is
still preserved.
And it's really difficult to
nail that really simple food
and to hold up that
kind of tradition.
And that restaurant's been
there for a really long time.
And I just really
appreciate the old--
I mean that's my go-to place.
JENNA TAYLOR: I love that.
What's another great
spot in Oakland?
TANYA HOLLAND: Well,
The Wolf just opened.
And I love their other
restaurant, Wood Tavern.
And their chef is a
woman, Yang, and they just
created a really
good vibe in there.
It's historically the Bay
Wolf for many, many years,
and he wanted to turn it over
to some local restauranteurs.
He actually asked me, but it
wasn't the right opportunity
for me.
And they've done
a fantastic job.
Again, food, it's really simple
and accessible but really
well done.
And yeah, I think that will
become my new favorite.
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh, good.
I'll have to check that one out.
TANYA HOLLAND: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: So you were
telling us a little bit
about your new spot.
So what's next?
Share.
TANYA HOLLAND: Well, I'm working
on a location in the Ferry
building.
I have a lease there.
And so we're
designing it and going
to call it Brown
Sugar Kitchen Counter.
Fingers crossed.
So we open up in
about six months.
Also working on a second--
I don't know, I'm
totally crazy--
location in Oakland.
Bigger and Badder
Brown Sugar Kitchen.
JENNA TAYLOR: I like it.
TANYA HOLLAND: And
a Napa location
hopefully in a couple years.
And then we'll see.
I want Brown Sugar
Kitchens everywhere.
So that's my goal.
I don't know who's
going to run them, but--
and then another cookbook
kind of in the works
and maybe some TV stuff.
JENNA TAYLOR: So
not too many things.
TANYA HOLLAND: Quiet at home.
JENNA TAYLOR: Resting
on your laurels.
I like it.
What about you?
JOANNE WEIR: So I am working--
I'm in pre-production
for my next TV show.
So it's called
"Plates and Places",
and we just shot in Morocco,
in Italy, and in Greece.
And we're shooting in October.
We're shooting in France,
from Lyon to Arles on a barge.
So that's a really exciting
project, because it's--
JENNA TAYLOR: It
sounds terrible.
JOANNE WEIR: I know.
JENNA TAYLOR: I'm sorry that
you have to go through that.
It's taxing, clearly.
JOANNE WEIR: Exactly,
I'm exhausted just
thinking about it.
But anyway so--
TANYA HOLLAND: I could work
as a translator if you wanted.
JOANNE WEIR: In Russian.
TANYA HOLLAND: No, in French.
[SPEAKING FRENCH] I
speak French better.
JOANNE WEIR: So I'm doing that.
And I'm also working on opening
a cafe within the University
of Massachusetts, which
is where I went to school,
a Mediterranean cafe.
It's funny, because I opened
Copita, which is Mexican.
I wrote 16 books about
the Mediterranean.
And I write one
book about tequila
and open a Mexican restaurant.
But I do like tequila.
And so I'm not a swilling
woman, but I like to kill it.
But anyway, so those
are the two projects
I'm working on right now.
And who knows if there's
going to be another Copita.
I'm sure there will be.
JENNA TAYLOR: And I know
you have a new endeavor,
but what's on the horizon?
TRACI DES JARDINS: Which new
endeavor are you talking about?
JENNA TAYLOR: What's
on the horizon?
TRACI DES JARDINS: Jardiniere
is turning 20 in September,
and so I'm kind of focused
on celebrating that.
JENNA TAYLOR: Rightfully
so, congratulations.
TRACI DES JARDINS: I like to say
nothing's new, because I've got
plenty on my plate right now.
But that's never true.
I'm thinking about the next
iteration of Jardiniere,
the 2.0 if you will.
It's time for a little
change and a shift in--
I think it's an homage to my
proteges that have come up
and are dedicated
and loyal to me
and letting them have a
say as to what they want
that restaurant to be like.
And so that's a
conversation we're having.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's a
really beautiful idea.
TRACI DES JARDINS: Yeah.
Yeah.
So it's time for me to
kind of pass the torch
and let the others really
rise up and have it be theirs.
So that's a great transition.
JENNA TAYLOR: And
how has it been
owning a spot in the Presidio?
It's a little different.
TRACI DES JARDINS: Yeah,
so the Presidio restaurants
are in conjunction with Bon
Appetit, a management company,
and--
JENNA TAYLOR: They
are also our partner.
TRACI DES JARDINS:
Yes, I know that.
And I've had incredible
opportunities
with and through Fedele Bauccio.
And he's just an
inspiration always.
He's a complete visionary.
And so the Presidio restaurants
are a work in progress.
I've got really incredibly
talented chefs out there,
and we're toiling in a way
that you get people to come out
to the new frontier, which--
JENNA TAYLOR: I guess
there hasn't traditionally
been that type of
offering in Presidio.
TRACI DES JARDINS: But
the Presidio-- and working
with the Presidio trust
has been incredible.
I mean, it's just an amazing
park and land and just
a really important part of
San Francisco in the future.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah, I'd love
to see it developed more
in that arena and just bring
a different type of traffic
to the Presidio, a different
type of experience there.
TRACI DES JARDINS:
Yeah, we have gardens,
and we're able to
grow food there.
And so it's--
I feel like we're just at the
beginning of our food program
there and where it can go.
And they're building
that whole parklands,
and so there's lots of exciting
stuff to come out there.
JENNA TAYLOR: That's great.
As we're talking,
I hear you guys
saying all of the different
things that you're doing
and this vast spectrum of
opportunities and roles
and hats that you wear.
How do you keep it all balanced?
And if you know, I really
want you to tell me,
because I'm trying
to figure it out.
TANYA HOLLAND: I think we
all agree, right, there
is no balance.
JOANNE WEIR: Yeah.
I'm more balanced now, though,
than I was in the past.
So it's much better.
God.
JENNA TAYLOR: So is it
just shifting your focus
over time, or in the
moment, whether it's
long term, short term?
TANYA HOLLAND: I think it
probably goes in cycles.
Like for me right now,
I feel like it's all
happening at once.
I have all these
new opportunities
to open operations.
But I was kind of on
a plateau for a while,
and then I was able to
really do a lot more
traveling for fun and other
things that I wanted to do.
So it's sort of like
you put a little--
put the time in the bank,
and then you work a lot.
And then you go and
you take some time off,
and that's kind of
how it goes, I think.
JOANNE WEIR: I do
think as a woman,
and as female, it is easier
to balance all those things.
Because I do many
things in one day.
I can be working on
one project and then
jump into something
else that I think
for me that's possible to do.
And so I can't see
doing it any other way.
I love doing what
I do, and I love
all the different projects.
If I only did one, it wouldn't
be good for me, I think.
TRACI DES JARDINS: When I
had only one restaurant,
I could be there all the time.
And it was only open
six days a week,
and so I pretty much was
in the building running it
for every hour that it was open.
As I expanded, I couldn't--
I figured out that I couldn't
perform a particular role
in any one of the
restaurants, or I was really
going to fall short in my
obligations to my team.
And so now I kind of float
between them and don't--
And so there's a
freedom in that.
And it's almost as--
the busier you get,
the easier it is
to take time off,
because you don't perform
a particular function
in any one of those places.
So I think unplugging
every once in a while--
and I don't think
I've really done it
in like three
years, because it's
so easy with all of our
devices to stay connected.
But I just went to Indonesia
and was in a really remote place
and didn't look at my email
or my phone for a whole week.
And it's just really
important to do that.
And it turned out--
I didn't think I was going to
have access to the internet,
but I did.
And I chose not to.
And it was an epiphany
for me, because I realized
I can make that choice.
I can just turn this stuff
off and not look at it.
JENNA TAYLOR: And the
world didn't end, right?
TRACI DES JARDINS:
It did not end.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's
always the fear.
TRACI DES JARDINS: Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Everything will be fine.
What does it look like
when you disconnect?
JOANNE WEIR: I don't
think I do it very often.
I really don't, not enough.
Doing that for one week,
all I'm thinking about
is how many emails
there would be after.
That's all--
TRACI DES JARDINS:
I'm still digging out.
JOANNE WEIR: Yeah,
absolutely, oh my god.
I just--
TRACI DES JARDINS:
But it was worth it.
JOANNE WEIR: Yes.
No, I-- when you said it, I
thought, I'm going to try that.
But no, I just don't
do it very often.
I mean, I travel and
I'm still looking
and I'm still staying connected.
I am.
I mean, if I don't look
at email for a whole day,
I think that's really
an accomplishment.
JENNA TAYLOR: It is.
I mean, it sounds like it is.
For you, I think
it absolutely is.
What about you, Tanya?
How do you get away from it?
TANYA HOLLAND: It's hard, too.
I mean, I've kind of
made a vow to myself
that I was going to go to
Maui at least once every year.
And if I'm in the water,
I can't take my phone.
I can't take my phone in
the water, so I can't--
or really on the
beach, get sand in it.
So that's like my getaway.
JENNA TAYLOR: I like that.
I feel like it's
a little bit sad
that we have to trick ourselves
into being disconnected.
TANYA HOLLAND: But as soon as
I get back to the hotel room,
I like--
JENNA TAYLOR: Well-balanced.
JOANNE WEIR: Checking
into the hotel,
can you give me the Wi-Fi code?
JENNA TAYLOR: I'm so
excited to talk to you,
but I would also like to
give our audience a chance
to ask some questions?
It's a little silly,
because I have
to repeat your question so
that people on the livestream
can hear it.
But if you can bear
with me through that,
I'd love to answer anything
anybody has to ask.
OK, I'm going to
be super concise--
how do you compare
the quality of food
here in America to food
elsewhere in the world?
It was much better
stated by you.
JOANNE WEIR: One thing
that I'd like to say,
because I work a
lot in Europe, is
it depends which
country you're in.
For example, in Italy, the
ingredients are incredible.
But I think we in
the Bay Area are
so spoiled that our food, our
ingredients, are exceptional.
But I do see, in
traveling around the US--
because I teach around
the US a lot too--
I see that the quality of food
is getting better and better
and better everywhere.
TANYA HOLLAND: Yeah, I agree
that we're just spoiled here.
So any place by
comparison, it's like, wow.
And like Joanne said,
depends on the country, too.
I think France-- where
we both learned to cook--
one of the reasons why
I loved being there
is there was a multi-acre garden
behind the school where I was.
And so we were
really at the source.
JOANNE WEIR: And in
markets every day.
TANYA HOLLAND: People
shop in markets.
That's their grocery store.
But other countries
maybe not the case.
What I saw when I was in
Kazakhstan two years ago--
I went as a culinary diplomat
through the State Department.
They have nothing to work with.
It was really-- potatoes,
a lot of root vegetables.
Seasonality is not
really a thing there.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah, I
grew up in the Bay Area.
And I moved to
Virginia when I was 18
and was shocked at the produce
selection or lack thereof.
So I think it's--
TANYA HOLLAND:
Where in Virginia?
JENNA TAYLOR: Roanoke.
TANYA HOLLAND: Oh.
I went to University
of Virginia.
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh, we could
talk about that UVA, yes.
I did not, but nearby.
What do you think, Tracy?
TRACI DES JARDINS: I
think there's always the--
I come from the Central Valley,
a small town in the Central
Valley, which is the bread
basket of the country, really.
A lot of food's grown out there.
But it all got exported and
moved from where I grew up.
So we had a really
paltry selection
of stuff in the
grocery stores there.
JENNA TAYLOR: The irony of that.
TRACI DES JARDINS: What's that?
JENNA TAYLOR: That's ridiculous.
TRACI DES JARDINS:
Yeah, it was insane.
It was like-- it was
moved from someplace else
to come to the grocery
store in the town.
So we grew a lot of our own
food in a kitchen garden.
If you've got a little tiny bit
of space, you can grow food.
And you see that a lot.
Like the farmer's market--
the Alemany Farmer's Market
in San Francisco--
a lot of those folks
are old ethnic
families that just grow
the stuff in their backyards.
And it's really interesting
that there's this opportunity
to grow food in all kinds
of little tiny places
and diversify the selection that
you have at your fingertips.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah, that's
something we care a lot about.
We were just talking about
sock gardening and ways
that we can move into
land that is severely
under utilized and put in high
performing farming systems,
just to bring fresh food to--
TRACI DES JARDINS: To
neighborhoods, communities
that it's really needed.
And it doesn't require
a lot of space.
And that's kind of the way
that it used to be done.
People really used to grow
their food in their backyard
and raise their own
chickens and eat those.
And it was just a different
relationship to food.
The industrialization of it
here has really, I think,
affected-- poorly--
our environment.
And diversity of
products that we have
has really had a negative
impact on food sources.
JENNA TAYLOR: I'm
hopeful that we're
swinging back in the
right direction with that.
TRACI DES JARDINS: I think
the interest goes a long way
and so does people's curiosity.
And that's where I can really
say, thank God for food TV,
and the information that
Google provides the world,
that we can really be
aspirational in what we seek.
JENNA TAYLOR: What
advice would you
give to your 25-year-old
self looking back?
JOANNE WEIR: Go.
You go first, that's fine.
TRACI DES JARDINS:
So I am completely
fascinated with Mexican food.
And if I could have
my time back that I've
put into my culinary career, I
would take a really deep dive
into Mexican food.
Because I think there's
still so much to discover,
and I wish I had the time
to go for that discovery.
So I think picking
an area of interest
and taking a deep dive into it--
even though I think we
are overstimulated now,
and there are so many
different opportunities
that I think that sometimes we
don't really thoroughly explore
a certain thing that we
might be interested in.
It could be baking.
It could be any
number of things--
to really take the time and
learn about a subject really
thoroughly.
JOANNE WEIR: I would say for me
is the best education that you
can possibly get, and
also the best experience,
and then making
connections along the way.
TANYA HOLLAND: I
probably would have
said, like, you should have
stayed in engineering school
and gotten an MBA
like I told you to.
JOANNE WEIR: But that
sounds so boring.
JENNA TAYLOR:
That's the problem.
It might be right, but
it's probably not right.
JOANNE WEIR: Well, unless you're
passionate about engineering.
You could be passionate
about engineering.
TANYA HOLLAND: But I
did follow my passion.
Family members thought
I was a little crazy,
and what was I doing?
Especially when I did have
opportunity to do other things.
But follow your
passion, for one.
And you do have to keep
reinvesting in yourself.
So don't always chase the money.
Sometimes the experience
you can get for a position
that might seem beneath you or
whatever, it's really worth it.
Now you don't have to buy
magazine subscriptions
like we did.
You can go online.
But I was always buying
cookbooks, attending events,
networking-- as Joanne said--
continue to make contacts with
people, make yourself known,
get to know people.
I wish that I had just
continued to seek out
like just a chef who was going
to take me under their wings.
I just kind of
settled into jobs.
I was like, OK, it's not
going to happen here,
but I'm just going
to work through this.
But I wish I had
just kept trying
to find that one chef who
would have mentored me.
But then I just was like,
I've got to do this on my own.
Because there was
a certain place
I wanted to be in my career.
JOANNE WEIR: You
mean like right now?
JENNA TAYLOR: How do you deal
with men taking direction
from you as a female
leader in the kitchen?
Has it been an issue for you?
JOANNE WEIR: Subtly.
TRACI DES JARDINS: That hasn't
really been an issue for me.
But I can be a fairly
aggressive person,
despite my little small self.
I could always prove
myself and do their jobs
better than they could.
And that was my way of proving
myself, and making sure--
I mean, size matters,
I guess, and sometimes
there were things
I couldn't pick up.
But other than that,
for the most part
I could work
circles around them.
And that was my method
of making them listen.
So I don't know if maybe
that's an answer that's
particular to me.
But I think dealing
with it head on,
and asking them the
question as to why
they don't think that they
should be listening to you,
and making the point.
JENNA TAYLOR: Call it out.
TANYA HOLLAND: Yeah.
I have to agree a
little bit with Traci.
But since we are talking gender,
I have to tell this story.
I was standing by the counter,
looking at my cooks one
day from outside,
just making sure
everything was going all right.
And there was a
couple next to me.
And the man looked at his
wife and said, oh, that guy
must be the head chef.
And I was just like, excuse me?
This perception
is still going on.
Just because he was the tall
white dude in the kitchen.
And like, that's my worst cook.
He's like-- I said it myself.
I have this guy.
JOANNE WEIR: He just
saw that, actually.
He's watching this.
TANYA HOLLAND: Well, there's
been a lot of tall white guys
that have come through.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's that
insidious, institutionalized
perception.
TANYA HOLLAND: Exactly.
JENNA TAYLOR: I'm so hopeful
it's shifting over time.
TANYA HOLLAND: We have to.
JENNA TAYLOR: We have time
for one more question.
Yeah.
How is risk?
And how do you address it?
And did it make a difference?
JOANNE WEIR: I had
just finished--
I studied in France for a
year with Madeleine Kamman.
And I came back, and
I thought I was going
to just conquer the world.
And there were two restaurants
that I was trying out
in-- one was Square One and
the other one was Chez Panisse.
And I remember deciding that
Chez Panisse was definitely
the place for me.
And I worked there for
two weeks for free.
And I remember every single day
I would meet with David Tanis,
and he would say--
would you come back tomorrow?
And I kept going, god, I've
got to come back tomorrow again
for free.
And I did that for
two weeks, and then it
went on for another week.
And then it went on
for a few more days.
And I remember
going home one night
and like crying and
going, oh my god, this
is really, really crazy.
Should I do this?
Should I really stick this out?
And the next day, thank
god, I got offered a job.
But it was really the
right thing for me,
and I'm so happy that I did it.
It was such an
extraordinary experience
for me to be there
for five years.
And even to this
day, I go back there
and I continue to work
because I just love the food,
I love the whole philosophy.
And it taught me so much
about my life and who I am
and how I hire people and
how I work with people.
So I wouldn't turn back.
JENNA TAYLOR: What
do you guys think?
TANYA HOLLAND:
Opening my restaurant
in West Oakland in 2008-- a lot
of people saw that as a risk,
and I was just desperate to
have a kitchen to work in.
And I knew that there was
a bit of a captive audience
in the community.
And I had to get in my car
to get a cup of coffee.
I lived about five
blocks from there.
And I just believed if I
built it, they would come.
And I called it a really
kind of happy accident,
because I was actually
shopping around a Creole Bistro
concept that was going
to be more upscale.
But I could not-- no
one would lease to me.
Because they said, you've
never owned a restaurant.
I was looking to be in the
financial district and business
district of Oakland.
And that's where I landed.
So you just have to go for it.
And like I said, now I have
this brand that it's beyond me.
I haven't even--
it's not something
that I-- it was never my
intention to get up at 5:00
AM to go cook eggs, OK?
But it's good.
Risks are worth it
most of the time.
Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Memorable
risks for you?
TRACI DES JARDINS: Every day.
The restaurant industry is
such a high risk business.
I don't think that there's
really anyone that's
risk averse that's in it.
But I've taken on this new
challenge in the last five
years to pick something that
I'm super afraid of every year
and overcome that fear.
And there are lots of them.
I used to be terrified to sit
and talk in front of people
and address a room
full of people.
It used to make me lose
sleep for three weeks.
And so I have picked a thing
and tried to get past it.
Recently I was in Indonesia.
And I've been in the
water my whole life,
and my family all scuba dived.
And I was a competitive
swimmer in school,
but I never wanted to get
certified to scuba dive.
Never wanted to be under
the water with a breathing
apparatus.
And I was super
afraid of sharks.
And I went to this eco preserve
there that has a ton of sharks.
And I got in the water with
them, and I went scuba diving.
And I have found this
new love for what
exists under the water.
And I've been avoiding
it my whole life
because I had these fears.
And so I pushed myself
through these things.
"Top Chef Masters"-- I
was terrified to go on TV
and do that as well
and made myself do it.
So sometimes if you can
push through that fear
and face up to
it, you can really
discover things about yourself
and find a different way
to express yourself.
JENNA TAYLOR: What a perfect
way to end this conversation.
I hope you all are as
inspired by that as I am.
Thank you so much for your time.
TANYA HOLLAND: Thank you.
JOANNE WEIR: Thanks, everyone.